because when you got a corset on my
waist was about 20 inches and you
absolutely can't breathe
sailing the high seas and getting into
swashbuckling pirate fights
may seem like a good time but
transforming yourself into the look of a
pirate can be less than desirable
to convincingly create scenes that take
place in the 1700s
it was vital that all the actors who
appeared on screen
looked the part the application of
makeup and prosthetics on an actor can
be a long and grueling process
the complex makeup and costumes worn by
actors can cause extreme discomfort
pain and in some cases physical injuries
which actors experience the most pain
and discomfort due to their makeup
and costumes skarsgard's bootstrap bill
turner had the unique distinction of
being the only member of davy jones crew
who wasn't computer generated however
that may not be as cool as it sounds
skarsgard had to undergo a grueling
makeup process
spending four hours in the chair to
achieve his rotting ship
look and was dubbed bulabase on set
because of the appearance
he said that they couldn't shoot for
more than three days straight because he
would get rashes from the makeup
and when he was done filming for the day
it took an additional hour and a half to
remove the heavy makeup and prosthetics
which wasn't too gentle on the skin we
applaud skarsgard for his commitment to
the role
and even though it sounds painful the
makeup looks great
captain salazar and his crew are some of
the coolest looking beings in the
pirates franchise
and while cgi had a big part in making
that look possible
practical effects were also a major part
in creating the effect
the makeup team went with a cracked
earth look for all the skin on the
cursed pirates
using prosthetics and paints javier
bardem
spent three and a half hours every day
in a chair
getting his makeup and prosthetics done
which became a very repetitive and
tedious process
bardem also had dots and some blue
screen on his face
to help the animators in post the end
result is a truly awesome effect
and all the time that went into making
it was well worth it
well it took me a little while to adjust
to the time frame hector barbosa is one
of the most memorable pirates from the
franchise
and his awesome look is a big part of
that it took about an
hour and a half for jeffrey rush to get
into his full pirate makeup
this included wearing fake rotten teeth
and wearing contact lenses to make his
eyes look more dead
and yellowish having fake teeth and
contact lenses in
all the time wasn't a comfortable
situation even though this caused rush
some discomfort
the end result is a grimy sword-wielding
captain
that is probably the image a lot of
people conjure when thinking of a
back on your pirate cockroaches it's
been
18 years since the curse of the black
pearl was released
so we'll forgive you if you forgot this
character
jacoby was one of barbosa's undead crew
members
who had a very specific physical
attribute his beard was on fire
and this wasn't a camera trick or cgi
the makeup and effects department made a
fake beard with wiring in the dreads
that were used to light incense
which actor vince lozano actually wore
while it was lit
they had to relight his beard between
takes and it's just as dangerous as it
sounds
lizano was burned several times the
beard would occasionally catch on fire
and it would also burn
other people when his beard would flip
into them you kind of always smell
burning hair around this guy
perhaps next time they should use cgi
instead
no fair rigetti is one of the most fun
and lovable characters in the series
with his signature look and fake eye
mackenzie crook
the actor behind righetti didn't
actually have a fake eye
instead he wore multiple different types
of contact lenses while filming
soft lenses were used to give his eyes a
certain grimy look
and hard lenses were used to represent
the fake eye as the lenses physically
bulged out crook's eye
these hard lenses can be very
uncomfortable but righty didn't let that
stop him from putting on
a memorable performance hi
before elizabeth swann became the badass
fighter on the seas
she was the pristine girl who dressed in
perfect clothing
this included a corset in the first
movie which wasn't very comfortable
nightly said that being in a corset is
positively awful
and that it makes it difficult to
breathe
ironically that is the plot point used
when she is in the corset in the movie
luckily for nightly the later movies saw
her wearing more loose-fitting clothing
to adjust for the extra movement and
fighting she was doing
the pirates of the caribbean movies are
extremely large in scale
and this includes a very big cast of
extras
any time you see a pirate on screen a
ton of time
and effort went into creating the look
pirate clothes arrived
new so the crew had to weather and age
them by putting them into a cement mixer
with bricks
they also dirtied the clothes which
meant actors were spending
hours in the hot sun with dirty clothes
on they had upwards of 50 makeup artists
at a time
getting the actors ready and keeping
them looking the right way throughout
the entire shoot
not the most pleasant or comfortable
experience but it definitely sells them
as real pirates
even though the main focus is on the
pirates don't forget the townsfolk that
appear in these films
like the pirate crews there were a ton
of townsfolk extras which required a lot
of clothing
costume designer pennyrose said for the
first film they ordered 900 pieces of
costuming for the extras
and these clothes weren't the most
comfortable to wear
some of the women had to wear tight
corsets just like keira knightley did
and some of the men had to wear tight
necker chiefs
the fittings were done on the fly as
actors were constantly swapping clothes
to get the proper fit
this made things chaotic and difficult
as there were so many extras
that it was nearly impossible to keep
track of it all
rose said the entire process was a mad
house especially since
most of it took place outside in the hot
sun but she definitely achieved the
right look
in the end johnny depp's portrayal of
captain jack sparrow is iconic
and so is his look to create the
signature look we know and love
depp had to go through a very specific
makeup and costuming process
to make sure his look remained
consistent across all
films this included a wig with
dreadlocks
his real beard braided with beads weaved
in his coat
pants boots and of course the iconic hat
what you may not know is that they
actually had multiple pairs of boots for
depth
because depth was getting wet so often
his boots would fill with water
making it difficult and uncomfortable to
walk the solution
was to create boots that could drain the
water more efficiently and the crew was
regularly switching out his boots
between takes
depp also had to wear special contact
lenses during shooting
the sunny days were so bright and
painful that he needed something to
protect his eyes
i had contact lenses made for him that
were actually sunglasses
naomi harris transformed her look to
play tia damma in dead man's chest and
at world's end
she wore a wig black lipstick black
eyeshadow tribal markings and gold and
dirt on her face
along with prosthetic teeth that would
clip in and out
she also filled her mouth with vegetable
dye before each take which meant she had
to say her lines with the dye dripping
out of her mouth
it wasn't the most comfortable
experience but it looked cool and we
appreciate everything she did for the
character
same story different versions and all
are true
to capture the amazing performance of
bill nye and transform him into davy
jones
the crew had an eye in a motion capture
suit for all of his scenes
he can be seen with white dots painted
on his face
along with some dark makeup around his
mouth and eyes
so all i had was little white dots on my
face i had to wear sad gray pajamas with
dots all over for the computers
as nye pointed out this isn't a
flattering costume and he felt left out
compared to his co-stars
sounds like his ego may have been
bruised a bit but even if he didn't look
that cool on set
he definitely looks like one of the
coolest characters in the finished movie
speaking of being jealous of your
co-star's wardrobe
jack davenport wasn't too fond about
norington's costume
he had to wear a proper powdered white
wig which he said
i look like an ice cream and these guys
just look so
cool when he learned he was going to be
in a pirate movie
he thought he was going to have the
chance to dress up and look cool
but instead he had to dress up like an
idiot
and he was not happy about it sorry
davenport
you win some you lose some that is
without doubt the worst pirate i have
ever seen
although getting into character for
these movies sounds like it was a hassle
it was definitely worth it for how it
looked on screen
we applaud these actors and actresses
for going through these
uncomfortable processes to provide us
with the characters
we know and love let us know if you
would like to see another pirates of the
caribbean movie